Imagine you find a magic lamp in an
antique store. You rub it, a genie
appears, and asks how it can help.
You burn it in the outline, so you say,
"I need the best engineer to help with
an impossible project at work."
And the genie grants your wish.
For me, the best engineer is probably
John Carmack from his eight days, so you
get Carmack.
But the genie had a sense of humor and
imposes restrictions, maybe for safety.
Carmack can only see one small part of
your code base, maybe 1/1000 of it.
And he remembers nothing he did before.
Every conversation starts fresh.
So, that would be maddening, right? You
would know there is a standard way to do
stuff, and Carmack wouldn't.
You would have to explain the same thing
over and over and over again.
You would have a genius on one side and
something deeply deficient on the other.
And that's what agents are.
Let me walk you through an example of
how many times we re-explain things in a
simple interaction.
We have four repos,
UI, module one, module two, and
platform. I want to change the UI and
propagate the change through the system.
Okay? First, we change the UI library.
Say we, I don't know, change a button or
whatever.
That's the first explanation,
unavoidable. We have to express the
intent, okay?
Then we publish it. We go to module one,
and we have to re-explain what just has
happened in the UI library, so it can
consume the package here.
Note that that's often a different
person, right? Every box in this diagram
can be done by a different person.
And then we discover that the published
UI library doesn't work with module one.
So, we go back
to UI,
and we have to re-explain the original
change and the issue.
Right? Because it's a new agent, it
doesn't know the original change. It
obviously doesn't know about the issue.
Let's say we fix it, right?
And uh publish it again.
We go and again we explain the new
change in the context of module one,
same module.
I mean, do the same for module two
again. And then we go to the platform
repo and we explain everything fits
together and we implement the change
there.
Let's imagine a week after release, a
bug appears in the UI component and we
have to fix it. So we start an agent in
the UI repo.
And we have to explain again the
original change from a week ago and this
production issue we're seeing.
So we have seven explanations for what
essentially is one change.
And also it may not be one person making
all these seven explanations,
but they still occurred, right? So
that's very very typical with agents.
So how do we solve it?
Well, there are many problems in here
that contribute to this experience, but
they roughly fall into two categories.
The first one is
that an agent essentially is repo bound.
Agent sees and changes generally one
repo at a time.
It never sees the whole system, which
can be hundreds or thousands of repos.
So that's kind of the space component of
the problem.
Second is amnesia. Agent forget the
work. Every session start with a blank
slate. The human becomes the memory in
this case. That's the time component of
the problem. Look at the two closer.
Take the repo boundary first.
Without a model how repos fit together,
the agent leans on the human to do the
research. It can't align the code with
the rest of the system. It couldn't
align the UI change with module one. The
human didn't explain it, so a bad
version shipped.
It can't reliably reference best
practices and standards either because
those often live in other repos.
Worse than even worse, the agent writes
to one repo at a time, it means it can't
validate changes downstream.
Modules one CI should have failed on the
UI change, but it didn't.
The agent can't update consumers at the
same time even though, you know, while
making the UI change, it has perfect
information to do so. It knows exactly
what it's doing.
So, the user has to re-explain stuff
imperfectly to each consumer.
Changing something across 20 repos means
re-explaining things 20 times. A lot of
developer time spent, but also a lot of
tokens burned.
The second category is that the agent
forgets.
The agent has no episodic memory. Every
session is a blank slate.
And the human, in this case, becomes the
memory.
Here's what the graph of your work
actually looks like.
At the bottom, there is a repository
graph. The artifacts your organization
produces
plus every open source repo you depend
on.
Maybe a thousand repos you own and tens
of thousands of open source repos.
At the top, there are all agentic
sessions that create and modify that
code.
Sessions relate to each other, repos
relate to each other.
So, this graph is a faithful picture of
the work in your organization.
It describes what's there at the bottom
and how it came to be
at the top.
That's what you want your agent to see.
Here's what it actually sees. There is
one session, one small fraction of the
code base, no memory, okay?
Because it sees so little, it leans on
the one who understands the system, the
developer.
Every developer has a part of that
graph, right? In their hand, at least in
the domain they know.
Agent generically speaking doesn't.
If this doesn't sound crazy, right?
Imagine an agent that could see one file
at a time maximum
and can only look five messages back.
Sort of constraint again both in space,
what can see, and time, how far in the
past it could see.
You would say that's impossible to work
in.
What we have now
is similar to that crazy picture.
And the more complex the organization
is, the more apparent it becomes.
I'll show you how we solved it.
Other organizations I talked to have
similar solutions, so
uh look at the problem and the solution
conceptually, not the specific tool,
although the tool is pretty cool.
We built
an agent agnostic meta harness called
Polygraph.
Okay, let me show you what it does and
how it fixes the issues we just
discussed.
The first idea
that we uh arrived at is that if a
GitHub user, any user, has access to
thousands of repos, some of them they
own,
many of them are open source,
we can analyze them
and extract a lot of metadata out of
them to build unified dependency graph.
Uh no line of code changes in those
repos, that all happens kind of on a
side, right? And then we can get this
metadata and feed it to the meta harness
and create an illusion of one big code
base the agent can read and write
anywhere.
This is my personal graph.
I want to have about 300 repos I own,
right? And thousands of open source
repos my projects depend on.
Polygraph computes what each one
produces, each repo, each project in
each repo, what each project in each
repo consumes package-wise, what API
they produce and consume, and lots of
other stuff, right? And this stitches
this together
uh into this like one big body of code
that your agent can work with.
So, let's see what it does, right? The
first thing it it does is
uh it lets you start a session to bring
the relevant
repositories in, right? So, what it
needs to do, it needs to
uh set up the source code,
install dependencies,
set up an agent for each repo,
wire them up so they can work together,
and provide a clean, beautiful GUI
to make non-trivial changes without
getting lost. I will show you how it all
works in a second,
right? So, that's kind of pull
information in.
Pulling information in is only one part
of the story, all right?
Honestly, it's an easy part. Making
changes is harder.
If you have 10 repos in one session, it
means you can have 10 pull requests, all
right? You need to run CI.
You need to coordinate all of it, right?
You need to do all this stuff, all
right? What if one of them fails, right?
Polygraph treats all the CI as one
vector.
Like if you look at the earlier example,
uh when we run CI for UI module one and
module two, if module one fails within a
polygraph session, it will figure out
who fixes it, whether module one needed
a patch or the UI component itself is
broken and incompatible with module one,
at which point everyone will need a
patch, right?
Polygraph lets you treat complex
multi-repo change as if it was a single
repo change.
The same machinery, by the way, fixes
episodic memory.
Because we capture your work, no matter
how many repos are involved, we We your
intent, the repository is involved, PRs.
We also capture all agent traces.
Because we capture all of this stuff, we
can relate it. So, now we can say your
work in one repo connects to another
work in another repo. Right? And all of
that lets us restore any session, any
piece of work on any machine, or
reference it from anywhere.
And I will show you again how it works
in a second.
What you get is an agent
with eidetic or photographic memory of
your entire organization. It understands
how repos are written, how they relate,
how they put together,
and remembers every session from every
repo by basically every developer.
Right? And that creates a completely
different development experience.
Let me show you.
First, let's look at how we create a
session, something simple.
You run a command,
and you pick some repositories from a
list.
Here's a tiny GitHub work with only
three repos because it's a demo.
I pick back end and a front end.
Let's say I need to make a change that,
you know, changes the API and has to
update both the API and how stuff is
being displayed.
I need to give my session a name.
I need to pick an agent from the ones I
have installed.
I picked Claude.
But any installed agent works same way.
Remember, Polygraph isn't an agent.
It's a meta harness around an agent that
makes them uh more capable.
And
in a second, uh the agent boots. And
here I could interact with it as if I
was in a single repo, even though
multiple repos are involved, right? I
could give it instructions.
It's going to uh plan out the change.
There is some cool animations in the UI
as well.
Eventually,
>> [snorts]
>> it figures out how the two repos relate
and what the change is. I can ask it to
implement the change.
My interaction with this
uh exactly same as if it I was working
in a single repo. The fact that there
are multiple repos involved is not
really important, right? Uh the only
uh part where it becomes important that
I have multiple pull requests, right? Uh
but I also get a polygraph session where
those pull requests are.
All right? If I look at the session, I
will see I have a description
uh that uh description of the session
describes the work conceptually uh kind
of bypassing the repo boundary, saying
we have to change stuff in this repo,
change stuff in that repo. It gives me a
good view of which repos are involved,
pull requests involved, CI in those
repos, everything I need to know. A lot
of this stuff is basically what I would
have in a single repo but many, right?
And I also have all the agent logs
captured as well, which is important for
resuming, which I'm going to show you in
a second.
Now it gets interesting.
I already saved one re-explanation.
I didn't re-explain the back end change
uh in the in the front end repo, right?
I explained the change once and I got it
implemented in both repos and it's all
in agreement. Now let's resume a
session.
Say I want a coworker to finish the back
end change. Perhaps they own the back
end repo.
I send them the session. They resume it
on their machine, all right? So this I'm
sending them the session.
They could run the command.
Uh different machine, different
everything. They use different terminal,
all right?
Uh they would reconstruct it on their
machine. They don't have the session,
right? They have never worked on it.
They they can pick an agent.
Uh the agent they pick could be a
different agent, right? I used Cloud in
the original session, but let's say
they're using a different one, Cortex.
The same setup happens to their machine,
same repos, same SHAs, everything set up
correctly.
Agent starts in a triple like in mine,
all right? They're all connected again,
so they work together. They're all
primed with a trace captured from my
machine, so the back end of the repo
agent on their machine has the same
shine and the same history. The front
end repo situation is the same. It's
It's checked out at the same at the
correct shard, has the agent running
with the correct history.
So, my agent was Claude. They coded, but
they share memory.
And they could actually actually make
changes in here as shown in a small
video.
Um but I think what the memory sharing
part is key, all right? Uh I can work,
they can work, and we can share our
memories as though we used to different
agents in different machine.
The full state of my session can I get
materialized on their machine.
It kind of less memory and more about
the state, right? The state of the world
that's attached to the session,
uh you know, is what enables them to
continue my session even though they had
didn't do anything with it originally.
It's close to the transporter in Star
Trek. Like a whole copy of my session is
all of its state materialized on their
machine so they can continue.
And that's how I often work when there
is a pull request for me to review and I
have questions,
I usually don't ask the person. I resume
their session on my machine, I get the
exact state, fully functional, zero
setup, and then I just talk to my agent
about the decisions we made, right?
>> [snorts]
>> Because all these decisions are in the
traces captured.
So, my agent knows exactly what the
other person talked to their agent.
Right?
So, a side note, this is also useful
when I want to switch from say Claude to
Codex mid-session when something goes
down, okay?
Okay.
Take the earlier case I talked about
where a bug landed in production.
Here, I'm going to reference the session
and say
it's basically broken.
Uh and you know, can you figure out
what's wrong and fix it?
The agent will look it up,
will download what it needs.
If description is like high-level
information is enough, that's great.
If not, it's going to pull relevant
repos, relevant shards,
agent logs, right? It's going to get all
this information from the original
session to reconstruct that state such
that it can do the necessary fixes as
shown here. He actually provided the
fix, right? I only had to say,
"This happened. There is a bug." That's
it. No extra information was required
for me to provide.
Okay.
So far, we have manually selected repos
and sessions, but we don't have to, all
right? Instead of selecting repos by
hand, I can also tell the agent what I
want. Remember that graph has all this
intelligence, right, about how repos
relate.
I could tell my agent, "Find every repo
that depends on a particular version of
a library
and update it." Right?
>> [snorts]
>> I mean, it knows, right? I I didn't have
to select them. It knows a lot of
metadata about what's going on. I can
also ask loose questions.
Things like, you know, uh
"What if I I want to write a blog post,
right, or an article?"
I could describe it and it will figure
out which repo is the most relevant
based on relationships between repos and
what's in them. Another example.
Let's say I want to add vector index
into the PR collection.
And I want to know if anyone at any
point did something relevant in any repo
that I can draw from.
So, in this case, if I do it, I'll see
that it will find several sessions that
appear to be relevant.
>> [snorts]
>> And I can load one of them or both of
them, right? Um it's useful for many
reasons. Uh let's just one small
example. It helps with best practices
and consistency.
Instead of doing stuff from scratch,
where, you know, every single
implementation is bespoke,
I can make it replicate the approach
used in the session by an engineer I
respect. Now, our code cross repos is
consistent. That's a big deal.
There is a lot more to it, of course. If
you are in a repo, I can ask, you know,
for sessions, it will prioritize
sessions that's relevant to the repo,
and vice versa. If I'm asking for repos,
it will look at my session and see what
similar sessions tend to bring in,
right? There's a lot of interesting
intelligence that make it a lot more
useful that appear at first glance,
okay?
Lastly,
uh everything so far I I used uh
everything I shown
uh used the Polygraph CLI, the current
meta harness CLI, to start it, and then
you can start Cloat or Cortex or
whatever from within it.
But, you don't have to use it this way.
So, in this case, I'm already in a Cloat
session, but it works with anything.
And I could just say, "Hey, you know, I
actually think a separate repo would be
useful. Like, maybe I'm working on a
Vitest plugin in this NX repo, and I
could say, 'Can you add the Vitest
uh repository to this session so I know
what's going on?'"
In this case, we'll engage Polygraph,
and it'll set it up, you know, configure
everything, and we'll bring the Vitest
library, which is a the Vitest repo, the
open-source repo, to my session. So, now
uh my agent can, you know,
explore it. It could, you know, uh
figure out how it works, and maybe
resolve an issue I have in my repo.
I much prefer this to say context seven,
because if I have the real code, the
agent can go really deep. So, the deep
problems are discovered all this way.
All right.
So, agents are constrained in space and
time.
They only see a small fraction of the
code base,
as they don't know the past, okay?
Uh and both limits could be lifted.
Polygraph uh gives agents access to the
entire code your organization can reach,
the one you own and open source. So,
it's no longer constrained in space. Any
agent can bring all of it.
Right? And it gives you agent a perfect
memory of what happened.
Every session, every decision made is
within reach.
Because it crosses developer boundaries,
not per developer, the agent can have
more context than any single developer.
Like a thousand engineers have an
organization, create all these sessions,
they all accessible to to each of them.
Almost like sort of the Borg. Every
agent can run by every developer
contributes to kind of one big this hive
mind, right?
So, uh if it's interesting, my name is
Victor. You can follow me on Twitter.
If you want to check it out, go to
try.poligraph.com
and see if it works for you. Thank you.